a well-executed plot twist can turn a
middling movie into a good movie and a
solid movie into a great movie but there
are just as many films that focus on
plot twists to the detriment of
everything else especially when they
start adding way too many twists for one
movie major spoiler alert for the
following films the ending of The Sixth
Sense was strong enough to make the
Shyamalan twist a recognizable and
anticipated moment in the writer
directors films unfortunately after
unbreakable he started slipping when it
came to the twist department perhaps
that was the reason the filmmaker went a
bit overboard in 2004 'he's the village
the film follows a group of people
living a modest life in a rural village
that is occasionally beset by monsters
as it turns out the creatures are just
village elders enacting a ritual to
encourage the younger residents to stay
in the village but when the blind
daughter of the chief elder ventures out
of the village to look for medicine
she's attacked by a real monster one
that actually turns out to be a mentally
disabled fellow villager wearing one of
the monster outfits the real twist is
that once she escaped the village it
turns out that what had appeared to be a
19th century community was actually just
a giant live-action roleplay the film
takes place in the modern day and the
village elders have bought and
maintained an isolated piece of land in
a wildlife preserve to start a new and
pure society we don't blame Shyamalan
for trying to one-up himself in terms of
twists but he might have gone a little
bit too far on this one Daniel Craig has
made his mark on the James Bond
character with his run on the franchise
the eagerly awaited Spectre was meant to
bring everything together introducing
fans to a new version of fan favorite
Bond villain Blofeld and showcasing his
ultra powerful and secretive
organization the titular Spectre
unfortunately the pressure might have
been too much for the filmmakers
Spectre is a completely bonkers film
that links together all of the previous
villains in the Craig films into being
part of the titular evil organization as
if that weren't enough it turns out that
Blofeld is actually bonds foster brother
from childhood who built his entire evil
organization for the purpose of
destroying bond who he sees as a rival
for his father's attention rather than
expanding the world of the franchise the
plot twist shrinks it all down instead
of going on adventures and proving
himself as a super spy against all
manner of charismatic super villains it
turns out that the through line of
Craig's Bond films was just a family
squabble with half a dozen Mission
Impossible films showcasing new and
inventive ways for Tom Cruise to nearly
kill himself for our amusement it might
be hard to remember how convoluted and
confusing the first Mission Impossible
is while waiter films in the franchise
would draw up on misdirection and
trickery the actual plot itself usually
isn't hard to follow that's not the case
with the first film abort
you read me in 1996's Mission Impossible
a routine IMF operation goes wrong when
Ethan is accused of being a mole and
hunted down by his own organization a
common occurrence in the franchise in
order to clear his name he has to break
into the CIA headquarters to steal a
list of CIA cover stories that the real
mole was trying to sell to an arms
dealer so in order to find out the real
mole Ethan has to pretend to be the mole
steal the real list to replace a fake
list then make sure the real list
doesn't actually make it to the arms
dealer while also trying to stop the
real mole from stealing the real list
all while staying alive and out of jail
simple right that's not even mentioning
the disavowed IMF agents triple agent
femme fatale and eerily realistic human
face masks thankfully most of the films
following stuck to simple plots and
insanely complicated stunts instead of
trying to outsmart audiences with a
confusing story is a simple favor a Paul
Feig comedy played extremely straight or
a murder-mystery drama with over-the-top
characters and plot twists maybe it's
both either way it's a movie with a
ludicrous number of insane plot twists
that read like half a dozen Agatha
Christie novels were stitched together
Anna Kendrick plays Stephanie a mummy
vlogger who falls into an increasingly
intimate friendship with Blake Lively as
Emily when Emily's body turns up a
little while later
Stephanie suspects that Emily's husband
Sean killed his wife in order to collect
on her life insurance that's when things
go totally off the rails Emily's body
wasn't really Emily at all instead it
was the body of Emily's twin sister
faith Emily's real name is hope and she
plans to pin the death of her twin on
Sean as revenge for him sleeping with
Stephanie it's all very soap opera
ultimately the day is saved when a fake
plan to extract a confession from Emily
with a fake gun is interrupted by Emily
trying to kill Sean in Stephanie with a
real gun which is then interrupted by a
SWAT team that was watching the events
happen
on Stephanie's mummy vlog livestream
simple twists and turns a part and
parcel of the mystery genre but a simple
favor just feels convoluted by the time
the credits roll when a movie is packed
to the brim with beloved actors it could
end up like a Coen Brothers film or you
could get collateral Beauty sure it
stars an absurd number of gifted actors
like Keira Knightley Helen Mirren Kate
Winslet Edward Norton and Will Smith
but despite the on-screen talent this
movie is out of its mind so what's this
star-studded film all about well the
story follows Howard an advertising
executive who lost his daughter to a
tragic accident years earlier ever since
he's been writing letters to the
abstract concepts of love time and death
meanwhile his crooked business partners
and estranged friends discover this
habit and hire actors to portray the
three abstract concepts why they want to
film Howard talking to them erase the
actors digitally and then submit the
recording to prove that Howard is unfit
to lead the company that they all work
at meanwhile Howard befriends a divorcee
whose own daughter died suddenly by the
end of the film she turns out to have
been Howard's actual wife and the two
have been treating each other as
strangers the whole time for some
bizarre reason in the end Howard does
actually leave the company when his
estranged friends plan is implemented
perfectly but he forgives them because
they were doing it to help him oh and
the actors playing love time and death
actually are the personifications of
love time and death who decided to help
Howard and his friends learn to love
again
talk about a head trip even if you enjoy
predicting plot twists before they
happen chances are good you won't be
able to guess the old secret Nazi
diamond one until after watching Inside
Man pay strict attention to what I say
because I choose my words carefully and
never repeat myself the film focuses on
a bank heist and the hostage negotiator
trying to keep the crooks from killing
any of the regular people trapped inside
the bank with them and as it turns out
the entire robbery is fake or at the
very least the bad guys weapons are and
after the cops mix up who's a hostage
and who's a robber it doesn't seem like
anything was actually stolen but then
there's the twist the bank robbers built
an entire fake wall in the vault for the
ringleader to wait inside until the cops
leave so he can steal some Nazi diamonds
that have been sitting inside the bank
since World War two while whodunits can
be a lot of fun inside man is more of a
why done it or a how done it how did no
one notice the fake wall why did the
thieving mastermind do all this to
enlighten one enterprising hostage
negotiator about Nazi shenanigans who's
checking to make sure any of this makes
sense
Nicolas Cage is known to audiences as a
wild actor that can be hard to
understand but despite his crazy
reputation his movies are generally
pretty well constructed and even-keeled
mostly
[Music]
that isn't the case with knowing a film
about how cages astrophysicist character
is the only one who can stop a global
extinction event after his son discovers
a series of numbers buried in a time
capsule that correspond to various
disasters in history cage notices the
numbers also predict disasters that
haven't happened yet worse one disaster
promises to wipe out the entire planet
Nicolas Cage using math to save the
planet from global extinction is a fine
premise on its own but that's before
knowing hits its stride throughout the
film mysterious strangers have been
following Kjus son and it turns out
they're actually aliens gathering up the
world's children to take them to another
planet for some reason cages character
is left alone on the planet to die as
every living organism is reduced to
ashes by a solar flare what does it all
mean
math is useless JJ Abrams Star Trek
reinvigorated the flagging franchise
with an updated aesthetic a young new
cast and a convenient explanation about
how it's a parallel story to the
original Star Trek television show
instead of simply being a reboot
following that success audiences
everywhere were eager to see what the
sequel would do with the newly fertile
story space as it turns out star trek
into darkness was basically just a
remake of Star Trek 2 the Wrath of Khan
despite many interviews from the
filmmakers denying it beforehand to the
point that Abrams publicly regrets the
secrecy Benedict Cumberbatch playing
Khan might be too much for many fans but
things get even worse when Captain James
T Kirk sacrifices himself to save his
crew in a nearly identical inverted shot
from Star Trek to where the original
Spock also takes one for the team
however while the original Star Trek
films at least waited for a sequel to
bring back Spock Kirk is up and blasting
the Beastie Boys again by the end of
into darkness thanks to a fortuitous
blood infusion from Khan's life-saving
body juice in other words just watch
Wrath of Khan instead of this darkness
Twilight Breaking Dawn Part two holds
the fewest plot twists here but that's
just because the filmmakers only needed
one to cross the line into too many
territory the story of the films are
simple human Bella Swan is enamored with
her vampire boyfriend Edward and wants
to marry him and become a vampire in
that order
by the time Breaking Dawn rolls around
Bella is newly turned and forced to team
up with her vampire in-laws to battle
against a secret vampire society that
wants to kill her half vampire baby
that's when things go off the rails
Bela her vampire family her werewolf
friends and the evil vampire Society
start killing each other in increasingly
violent ways it's a frenetic turbine of
CGI carnage that ends with most of the
fan favorite characters dead it's also a
complete fabrication a psychic vision
from one of the super-powered vampires
to show what would have gone down had
the bubble actually happened for mega
fans of the book it likely left them
tense in their seats for everyone else
the revelation that it was all a dream
probably left them scratching their
heads either way one plot twist was one
too many if you had anything about
Netflix's original horror movie but
perfection chances are good that you
were encouraged to go in as ill-informed
as possible that's because the film has
so many twists but part of the pleasure
of it is feeling unsure of what the
actual story is about and partly because
it doesn't really hold together by the
end true the film starts simply enough
Charlotte a former cellist prodigy is
forced to hang up her bow to take care
of an ailing mother in turn her former
mentors have found a replacement in
Lizzie that's when things get weird
Bizzy seems to get infected by an
earlier foreshadowed flu which
eventually culminates in her
ting up wriggling maggots and chopping
off her own arm to stop the bugs inside
her body from devouring her but actually
the entire sequence was engineered by
Charlotte who drugged Lizzie in order to
ruin the younger woman's musical career
pharmacy is open for business
what is that a of the dog it's the best
cure in yet another twist it turns out
that Charlotte had good intentions she
was trying to help Bizzy escape a life
of musical domination and sexual
violence at the hands of their shared
mentor it also turns out that Lizzie
thinks it's worth the pain in order to
truly excel as a musician but wait we're
not done yet
it then actually turns out that she and
Charlotte engineered it all to trap
their former teacher chop off his arms
and legs and play a duet together when a
film is almost too confusing to
summarize you know you've got too many
plot twists check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]